وبحسب التقارير، وافقت إسرائيل على اقتراح الوسطاء
للصفقة التي ستتضمن في مرحلتها الأولى إطلاق سراح
النساء المسنات والمريضات مقابل آلاف الإرهابيين
والآن الجميع ينتظر جواب حماس بنعم نحن كذلك
نحن نتحدث في الواقع عن حاوية حول ماتفا يتم الترويج لها على النحو التالي
وكانت القمة في باريس أمس شارك فيها جميع رؤساء المخابرات
الجلوس في نفس الغرفة ماذا يعني هذا الشيء؟
بادئ ذي بدء، تقريبًا أفرغ سجن ابنتي
السجن هنا في إسرائيل يُثري الفلسطينيين، ولكن أيضًا
نقطتان أخريان مهمتان للغاية
وفي هذا السياق، يقول الناخبون الإسرائيليون أولاً
اليوم، هذه الأرقام يمكن أن تتغير
المفاوضات مستمرة طوال الوقت وهذه الأرقام
ليس نهائيا ولكن الأهم من ذلك هو أنه ضروري
اثنان للتانجو وثلاثة إسرائيل على جانب واحد ولكن على جانب واحد
والثاني لديه همز وحمص حتى الآن لم يسلموا
إجابتها هي لسبب بسيط وهو أن رئيس وزراء قطر
أقول للناخبين الإسرائيليين أمس في باريس إنني بحاجة لذلك
بضعة أيام لتلقي منهم
عد
لاحظ أنه يستخدم مصطلحًا بناءًا
وليس منتجا بناءا فهو كفؤ أو
أن الآلية عملت وأنهم تحدثوا مع بعضهم البعض لم يكن كذلك
منتج يعني أنه ليس لديه أي منتجات حتى الآن
ما حدث هناك كان بناء للغاية أو
منتجة لا أعرف يتم إجراؤها بين
رفقاء العريس ليسوا مع العريس السعيد نفسه ونحن كذلك
علينا أن ننتظر حتى تخرج بعض المشاكل
عناء لست مستعدا ولكني أتكلم من سيعيش
سينو هذه الحاجة الأمريكية اليائسة لإنتاج كل شيء
الوقت شعور بقوة الإرادة
ومن هذه العملية لا تزال التعقيدات موجودة
فهل ستوافق الحكومة الحالية على اتفاق كذا وكذا؟
على المستوى السياسي الأول، ينبغي أن يقال هذا بالفعل
أن نتنياهو يعطي مثل هذا الحبل المهم للرعايا
والسماح لهم بالموافقة على هذا الشيء يعرضك بالفعل للخطر
رقبته السياسية نسمع ردود الأفعال
ومن المؤكد أنهم لن يرحلوا عن سموتريتز بن جفير
ولهذا السبب قد ينسحبون من الائتلاف
لا يقول أنهم سيقودونني إلى الانتخابات، أليس كذلك؟
الأغلبية في الحكومة، في رأيي، نعم، لكنها ليست أغلبية
هذه السيارة ستؤذيه كثيرًا جدًا داخل القاعدة
دعمه لبايز لأنه سيكون في اليوم التالي
طوال الوقت الذي كنا نتحدث فيه عن ذلك، كان ذلك بعد الساعة السادسة
الحرب لأنها ستصبح فجأة شهرين أو ثلاثة أشهر
إن عدم وجود قتال هو وقت طويل جدًا
جلب المظاهرات يمكن أن يجلب
آيسن كوت جانز معسكر الدولة للتقاعد
من وجهة نظر الحكومة بالنسبة لنتنياهو، فإن هذا خطر كبير جدًا
إنه لأمر رائع أن نذهب لمثل هذه الصفقة كما قلنا
يعرف الكثير من الناس أن نتنياهو يوافق من الماضي
أن يكون معتدلاً في مختلف القضايا السياسية
أنواع الأشياء التي تقولها، هذا هو نتنياهو لذلك
يوافق ثم تدرك أنه مؤمن بالخرافات نوعًا ما
قد يكون الأمر هو قتل الطرف الآخر
هذا النوع مما يسميه الأمريكيون رجل الطوب
هذا الشكل، هذا المشي اللطيف على الخط
وأنه إذا قتلته حماس فيمكنه أن يأتي
لعائلات المختطفين للجمهور الإسرائيلي أن يقول
لقد ذهبت إلى أبعد من ذلك حيث أنه ليس لدينا سوى عدو
ما عليك سوى أن تهزمه في الميدان، نعم، هذه تغريدة
من الآن فصاعدا من قبل وزير التربية والتعليم يوآف كيش
انشرها في هذه اللحظات إذا كان هو بالفعل
التخطيط هو تخطيط قريب منه، لذلك للأسف
هذه خطة شراء لحماس، وهي خطة محظورة
أوافق عليه تحت أي ظرف من الظروف القبض على
الحرب العادلة في تاريخنا للحصول على نصيب
من الشواطئ دون قرار وسط إطلاق سراح آلاف القتلة
من السجون التي ستقتلنا مرة أخرى هو الجنون
ويبدو لي أن هذا يدل على ذلك حتى بين المعسكر
والتي من المفترض أن تدعم صفقة كيش بركات جالانت هناك أيضاً
سيكون من الصعب جدًا تمرير مثل هذه الصفقة بالرغم من ذلك
لا يوجد حتى الآن إجماع من خمسة، ولا توجد تفاصيل نهائية
لا يزال هناك طريق طويل لنقطعه، دعنا نقول فقط أننا قطعنا شوطا طويلا
لقد خرجنا من المدخل المغلق، لكن الطريق ما زال طويلاً
لقد أسعدني البيان الذي صدر عن كبار الضباط
صفقة يمكن على المستوى السياسي أن تحقق إطلاقاً سريعاً
أي بعد الفشل الذريع للجيش في 7
في أكتوبر، ليس هناك حقا أي قدرة للجيش حقا
لمعارضة مثل هذه الصفقة بخصوص صفقة المختطفين نحن
ونسمع في وسائل الإعلام عن اتفاقيات فعلية للتوقف
ومعنى هذا الشيء هو الحرب بكل الطرق
الإنجازات التي حققناها بالدم
إن مقاتلينا هم حقيقة ستسمح، لا سمح الله، لحماس بالسيطرة عليها
مرة أخرى على الأراضي ويعرض سكان الجنوب للخطر مرة أخرى
إن دولة إسرائيل مذيعة سيئة للغاية اليوم وفي البحر
نحن في الجوار ولن يحدث ذلك، وكذلك فعل الإرهابيون المأجورون
كتلة ستغير كل يهودي في إسرائيل والعالم المجاور
بالنسبة لعمليات الاختطاف، لن نوافق أبدًا على صفقة
مثل هذا
فترة، لا يوجد اتفاق، فترة، دعونا نضع الأمر على الطاولة
الأشياء التي نشرت بالأمس ليست صفقة
لا أفعل ذلك من خلال المرور بأجزاء كبيرة من خزانة الحرب
يمكن أن أقول لا لمجلس الوزراء الحرب بأكمله ليس كذلك
تمرير الأغلبية في مجلس الوزراء الحربي هناك بعض
في مجلس الوزراء الحربي كانوا سيقبلون الصفقة
هذا منحل
لن أتوسع في الموضوع لأن الأمر الأساسي مطلوب
أن يكون الأمر لا يمرر رئيس الوزراء ليس كذلك
مرور وزير الدفاع لا يمر ولا توجد فترة
تعامل بهذه الطريقة بالمناسبة
المعنى